foreign
guys let's uh let's watch a little TV
some big announcements coming from DC's
mayor and the DC Health Department
within just the last hour a state of
emergency declared and recommending that
large Gatherings including conferences
and conventions be postponed or canceled
oh the news is not looking good is it a
bankstown mother and daughter have been
charged after a fight over toilet paper
in Woolworths that's not good oh boy yes
uh zombie attack in Alexandria
let's look at the five-day forecast and
we'll see the temperatures are still
fluctuating but the chances of death
have stabilized at about 99.99
oh no
no mama I'm worried about Nathan that
boy licks everything he's been licking
the slide at the Chick-fil-A play place
he's been licking the floors in the
public bathroom two hours later he likes
to lick the toilets he likes to lick his
brothers he likes to lick dogs if
anyone's going to get this virus it's
going to be Nathan
hey Nathan you feeling okay there buddy
guys I think Nathan's infected
[Music]
get away run faster
he has a runny nose he's sneezing
maintain social distancing on faster
[Music]
Mommy I want to snap with you
get the Nerf guns you ready Tommy
you ready Mama
get ready guys here he comes fire
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
he's gonna come and get us run
Prime
I got no bullets throw it at him stop
him throw it at him
we need more toilet paper why didn't we
buy more toilet paper run run
ah get in the bathroom ah go get it
right here
oh okay
we gotta deal with this situation we've
got Nathan trapped in the basement
there's no time for dabbing zombies are
taking over a family a pandemic is over
the world no dabbing well Rebecca you
stay up here I'm gonna go downstairs and
deal with child all right Tommy move the
barricade all right he's down here
somewhere so dark
all right Nathan I know you're down here
I'm not gonna hurt you I'm just gonna
hit you with my broom and dunk you in
hand sanitizer for a few days what's
what's
up
[Music]
mommy no
Becca what happened you came out of
nowhere he got Tommy oh oh no they're
coming we gotta run
we can't get this stuff off go on run
come on
all right Becca we gotta get out of here
we can't leave the kids we gotta leave
the children all they ever do is pick
their nose and lick things we'll be
better off this way we'll be safe don't
worry
[Applause]
oh
my God
all right I gotta make a Last Stand I'm
not getting sick
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
wait are you coughing on your darts
you're monsters
[Music]
oh no I'm out of bullets make sure
there's one bullet left for myself
[Applause]
oh don't cough on me
[Applause]
well guys I hope you enjoyed this video
if you want to see more nerf war skits
from the outdoor Boys YouTube channel
don't forget to click subscribe and
check the video description for links to
our other videos stay safe out there and
wash your hands and we'll see you next
Saturday if you like this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this and don't
forget to click subscribe so you can see
other great videos every Saturday
morning hit that Bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]